نوع جديد من فيروس كورونا
تم تحديده لأول مرة في البرازيل
موجود الآن في الولايات المتحدة ،
تم اكتشاف البديل في مريض من ولاية مينيسوتا
سافر مؤخرًا إلى البرازيل وينضم
إلينا الآن هو كبير المراسلين الطبيين لـ
CNN الدكتور سانجاي جوبتا ،
ما الذي يعذرك يا رجل مهذب جيدًا
ماذا فعلت مع  طبيبنا الرائع ذو الشعر الممسحة ،
قررت أن أحصل على كل شيء
احترافي من أجلكم يا رفاق الذين
تعرفهم فقدوا حوالي جنيهين بالأمس ،
أعتقد أن
هذا هو أقصى ما يمكنني إخباره
بأول قصة شعرك للوباء
، لا بأس ، هل هذا هو ما تمسك به بالأمس
بمظهر سانجاي  في هذا الفيديو ، هل أتيت للتو
من
هذا النوع من الطريقة التي أعرف بها عادةً أن
هذا هو الجزء غير المعتاد
هنا
آه نعم الكثير من الشعر آه مظهر مختلف جدًا
الآن ،
أشعر بالنظافة أشعر أنني بحالة
جيدة  نحرز تقدمًا كدولة ،
أعني أنني أعتقد أننا لسنا بحاجة إلى مثال أفضل
من مدى تقدمنا في الوباء ، حس
ًا ، سانجاي ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك على مش
ركة تلك اللحظة معنا